[Music]
the rugged mountainous terrain of India
contains unmatched adventure their three
historic railways are grouped into a
single world heritage site known as the
mountain railways of India the
Darjeeling Himalayan railway the Nilgiri
mountain railway and the Colca Shimla
railway are a Holy Trinity for train
aficionados but they're more than just
relics of British colonization all three
are still fully operational today and a
ride on any of them reveals the
incredible engineering that connected
these rugged locales the Darjeeling
Himalayan railway often called the toy
train because of its diminutive size
opened in 1881 the serpentine track
gained serious altitude by employing an
endless series of switchbacks hairpin
turns and bridges
the Nilgiri mountain railway spans 29
miles of mountainous terrain in tamil
nadu state this steam-driven line climbs
through southern jungles rising towards
its terminus at Otago mandalam the
kalka-shimla railway line climbs close
to a mile high taking passengers through
102 tunnels and across 864 bridges if
the journey is as important as the
destination then the mountain railways
of India are an essential travel
experience there are intriguing stops
along each of these lines leaving it up
to the traveler to decide how long to
linger along this iconic route
[Music]